Speaker 1: This is an unbelievable story.
You know, the right loves to talk about ballot
drop boxes.
They're bad, they're not secure or they're
unreliable.
And yet the reason that they are not as trusted
by some Americans is because Republicans are
saying you can't trust them.
It's a self-fulfilling prophecy.
It's a vicious circle.
It's endless.
And now individuals believed to be right wingers
have been spotted, in some cases armed at
Arizona ballot drop boxes.
Arizona Secretary of State Katie Hobbs received
a report this week about an alleged incident
of voter intimidation.
Video was obtained by The Washington Post.
And we're going to play the video here for
you.
And I will describe what is visible.
There is a man who parks at one of these ballot
drop boxes and he walks over and he dumps
in his ballot.
Perfectly legal.
That's what it's there for.
This was on October 17th.
This is an early voting drop box.
And what you see is that after he walks away.
Something gets his attention right across
the street.
He's he's apparently engaging with someone
right across the street.
And it seems to start to become sort of combative.
And the man later reported that he was being
watched, he was being photographed, and he
was being heckled as he used that ballot drop
box.
And again, if you're listening, I'm describing
what's on video.
The individual eventually getting into his
car, backing up and ultimately driving away.
But what he says happened was that people
were harassing him for using that drop box.
And he ultimately decided to.
Seems like back all the way out and go in
a different direction.
That is exhibit number one.
We then learned about on Friday, two armed
individuals dressed in tactical gear showed
up at a mesa, Arizona, ballot drop box.
We have pictures here.
Eventually, the Maricopa County Sheriff's
Office arrived and the individuals left.
There are folks here you see wearing I don't
even know the terms for this stuff.
They've got like a I can't tell if that is
a leg, a band, a leg holster of some kind
with one individual.
They seem to have a tactical vest, possibly
a camera.
Who knows what it is that that they all have.
But reportedly armed individuals in tactical
gear.
Again, allegedly, they're too apparently there
to harass and intimidate and all of the things
that you would imagine they would be doing.
And then there is an additional report of
people just hanging out outside Maricopa County
elections headquarters in Arizona, outside
one of two ballot drop boxes.
They have their own cameras rolling.
They are filming the drop boxes.
And here are people and they're all playing
coy.
I can't really tell you what I'm doing here.
Check this out.
So what we're seeing right now is just a bunch
of cameras pointing at the drop boxes.
Speaker 2: What was the name of the group
you're with again?
Clean Elections USA.
Speaker 1: Clean Elections USA.
Speaker 2: And you've been out here how long?
Speaker 1: I can't answer that.
Okay.
They claim that they have not said anything
to people dropping off ballots.
They just have cameras pointed at the drop
boxes.
They have, you know, a dog, a bunch of cameras,
food, etc., etc..
Now, individually.
Is it against the law to just have a camera
across the parking lot from a Dropbox?
I don't know.
And that's what's being explored right now.
But the totality of what's going on in Arizona
and I don't care who's doing it, if you came
to me with tears in your eyes and said, Sir,
these are all Democrats, I would say it's
still wrong.
I don't care who's doing it.
This is all a form of voter intimidation.
And there's also a story here of what appears
to be essentially inaction by law enforcement,
which is another part of this that we're exploring
and may have more information about about
for you tomorrow.
They are.
You know, it's the other day, Marco Rubio.
Marco Rubio said, listen.
People don't trust these ballot drop boxes.
Right.
But they don't trust them because you told
them they shouldn't be trusted.
It's completely circular in every way.
And now in order to set to be able to justify
their own claims that these drop boxes are
just trouble, they are creating trouble at
the drop boxes.
These are horrible people.
This is not pro-democracy behavior by any
means.
And we have to see to it that it is stopped
in Arizona